we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p couple
voicemails today i mentioned recently
and we got a call I believe it was
Grover and maybe a couple other people
saying that they would be interested in
me doing explainer videos about not only
investment but also cryptocurrency
here's one caller who at least seems to
agree with that idea hey David I would
really like it if you would do a series
of videos on cryptocurrency there's more
videos on crypto currencies and in more
videos on investing I think a lot of
your audience is probably pretty young
every young myself and recently got into
investing I think it's something that a
lot of people don't realize how much
potential there is and just putting a
little bit your money aside and I think
it'd be really beneficial especially
with this stock market doing pretty good
this year I don't know if that's gonna
last but yeah I hear would be really
awesome okay so we got a lot of messages
like that which really encouraged me to
do content about cryptocurrency and
investment and all sorts of other
related topics but what concerns me is
the subject the content of this next
voicemail that came in listen to this
hey David I just um put about half my
bank account into Bitcoin which is about
eight hundred dollars
so thanks upon your advice I'm going to
be rich and I'm investing in Bitcoin
thank you David yeah thank you for all
your advice know that is someone who is
an admitted troll that's the guy from
Texas who called in and said yeah about
half my calls are trolling but it
actually is a concern I have which is
even though if we talked about that
stuff just because I'm telling you how
you would buy Bitcoin if you wanted to
that doesn't mean I'm recommending that
you buy Bitcoin and my concern is and
that that's a troll that's not real but
my concern would be Pat that people
would interpret me telling you how to
buy Bitcoin as a particular
recommendation and that's my concern
about doing that type of content how
many times am I gonna have to every
other cent and say none of this is
investment advice I think we might as
well just put a watermark on the entire
videos that because this is not a biker
advice yeah I don't know that doesn't is
the last thing I want to do is have
people that's fake but imagine if
someone did at $12,000
Bitcoin value invest half of their money
and then it drops to $8,000 and then
they lose a third of their money
instantly I don't want to be responsible
for that stuff and I mean that caller
calls in and says that half the time
he's trolling it half the time he's not
so how do we know which half the time
he's trolling trolling there was he
trolling when he told us that he trolls
half the time I think that he's trolling
there at least yeah I hope that he
didn't actually invest half his money in
Bitcoin because of some completely
non-existent recommendation that I
clearly never actually made but anyway
we are thinking about how to do
cryptocurrency type explainer videos and
maybe some other investment type videos
we've got a great bonus show for you
today the Supreme Court may be sounding
skeptical about that Colorado Baker's
refusal to make a gay wedding cake will
also talk about children in Mexico
falling sick around a Mexican lake under
sort of odd circumstances and we'll also
talk about upcoming website changes all
of that and more on the bonus show david
pakman.com slash membership patreon.com
slash david pakman show